[Applause]
with limited health care food supplies
and clean water
the navajo and hopi communities faced a
humanitarian crisis
at one point we surpassed new york city
for the most amount of positive cases
and deaths
per capita but help arrived from an
unlikely source
donations now totaling one million
dollars
the irish were repaying their debt high
surprised were you when uh
donations started to flood in from
ireland
did you know why they were coming we
started looking into it and we started
seeing
messages um very sweet messages
and that's when i learned about the
choctaw nation
and their generous gift that they gave
to
ireland during the potato famine and
it just it touched our hearts it was
1847 the height of the potato famine
when the struggling choctaw community
sent 170
to ireland nearly two centuries later
their kindness has been returned with
interest
alan o'kelly shane baldwin
larry rooney irish donation after irish
donation
the journalist whose retweet sent the
appeal viral
says ireland had never forgotten getting
help from so far away
created a bond and a memory of that
historical kindness that endures to this
day
and it's remembered in ireland it's it
started off a kind of
a chain of events through history in
which irish people have
and native american people have had a
sense of solidarity and kinship
that's been demonstrated a couple of
times throughout history and
is still remembered today commissioned
in gratitude for that famine
this sculpture in cork has new meaning
representing the enduring power of
kindness
for two communities with kindred spirits
it's a story we'll tell to our children
and to our children's children
we'll never forget the kindness of the
irish
david blevins sky news